joining me in the studio is Professor
Colin Debbie from the gilma Helmholtz
Centre for ocean research in Kiel and he
will be on board the vessel was Donna
for the first research trip now it's
actually the most fascinating piece of
equipment on board the sauna for you for
me it's the echo sounder although there
are lots of really cool things on that
ship but the echo sounder as we drive
along and the echo Sounders shooting its
sound waves into the water
it's like shining a torch into somewhere
you've never been before like exploring
an old house that you've just found or
something you you see new things every
day new things like what you brought us
here a piece of stone well what's so
special about it
yeah I'm a geologist so I carry pieces
of stone around in my pocket all the
time and not really this is actually the
stone that's probably the most common
stone on the surface of our planet this
covers about 60% of the whole earth
it's a lava stone that's come out of the
ocean floor about 1,200 degrees and
there's met very cold seawater the salty
water down there is about zero degrees
and it's from the glass skin on the top
as you can see would it look any
different if it was lava from the land
on land that cooling that rapid cooling
doesn't happen so you very seldom see
glass on on lavas on land ever on the
seafloor they're all glassy and what are
you actually interested in when you go
down to the deep sea in three thousand
or even six thousand meters I'm
personally interested in how this planet
works so for example for that rock where
did where was it produced where did the
melt originated that form that volcanic
eruption it's to do with plate tectonics
it's to do with how the surface of the
earth where the continents are how that
all happened how the Atlantic Ridge
maize may be also formed this is from
the mid-atlantic ridge edge exactly to
do with the mid-atlantic ridge in the
mid-atlantic ridge back through time
because the 80 or 90 million years ago
you could walk from africa to north
america now you can't okay and if you go
down to the deep sea you will also find
lots of minerals and resources is that
of interest to you too
yeah sure associated with the with the
volcanoes that produce these lavas there
are lots of hot water there's lots of
minerals being deposited we study them
we stood the animals that live there as
well they're really little oases of life
on the sea floor where this hot water
comes down so that could also be that
life originated in the deep sea it's one
of the very strong theories that life
originated in the deep sea yes and
there's another theory that lie you
believe in it
yes I do actually and it may well be
that that life is also originating on
other planets that have similar
eruptions on their seafloor so water
covered planets could equally well be
capable of pretty amazing if you look at
these resources down in the deep sea I
mean do you think it would be very
harmful to the organisms there if we
started to mine it I really don't know
because really we don't know what
organisms are there that's part of the
the reason for wanting these research
vessels and and trying to get more
presence in the deep sea is that we
really know very very little about the
deep sea floor it seems like a pretty
weird and strange world down there isn't
it it is I've actually dived down there
in a submersible and it's like leaving
the planet when I came back from the
submersible I knew how an astronaut felt
amazing and so is the work on sana is it
is it always just work or is there also
a life after work of course we work 24
hours a day and don't sleep no we of
course of course we're humans and it's
actually a research cruise like this is
it is some extent a social experiment
you have to get on with all sorts of
different people there's not very much
personal space on the ship most of the
cabins a single cabinet so you can
actually close your door and you've got
your little square meters but sometimes
you can you can't avoid problems it's a
problem there you've got to deal with it
your set sail on the 15th of December we
wish you lots of luck thanks very much
for the talk